[Music]  [Music]  where's  oh hey there baby the hell are you doing  here  i'm commissioned to this flight we  haven't got time for this right now put  her in the sperry until we get up in the  air i'm supposed to guard this i'll  guard it for you  content to confidential  [Music]  what's your name honey flight officer  garrett ain't no women in the air corps  i'm a flight mechanic and a pilot you're  not a pilot  you're a delivery girl  sir requesting permission to fire an  enemy attacker  you wouldn't even know how to fire a gun  i was being polite  she was right who the hell are you miss  garrett what is she here for  did you hear that what the hell is that  racket there's something on top of the  plane something on the goddamn time  here they come  these irregularities started with that  package  you have no idea how far i'll go how did  you get up here  welcome back to the party baby  strapping yes ma'am  [Music]  you